welcome back everyone this is part three
in our series on nli this is our chance
to start getting a little introspective
and think more about developing truly
robust systems so our topic is going to
be
set artifacts and adversarial testing
i'm pleased to report that a lot of the
discussion in this area actually traces
in the nli context to a course project
for this class in 2016 landon kesselman
observed that for nli hypothesis only
models were surprisingly strong and what
i mean by hypothesis only model is that
these are models that literally throw
away the premise text and reason
entirely in terms of the hypothesis so
to the extent that models can succeed
despite having no information about the
premise we might really worry about
whether we're solving the task we think
we're solving because after all nli is
supposed to be about the reasoning
relationship between premise and
hypothesis and you would not expect it
to be successful if you were given only
the hypothesis but what lan had observed
is that these models were surprisingly
strong
subsequently and i think partly
independently a number of other groups
made the same sort of observation about
a variety of nli benchmarks
and that kind of leads us to the
conclusion that at least for snli
averaging across a whole lot of
different systems
hypothesis only baselines are typically
operating in the range of about 65 to 70
accuracy again that's eye opening
because chance performance would be 33
and this is showing us that there is
some unusual bias in the hypothesis that
is allowing us to neglect the premise
and still have a lot of predictive
capacity
the reason for this is likely to do to
what we're going to call artifacts in
these data sets and just for a few
examples here we can observe that
specific claims are likely to be
premises and entailment cases and
correspondingly general claims are
likely to be hypotheses and entailment
cases just think at the lexical level if
you have a pair like turtle and animal
you know you have a very specific term
in the premise and a very general term
in the hypothesis that's an entailment
relation and if you did just drop off
the premise and looked only at the
hypothesis animal you might still have a
pretty good guess that that's going to
be an entailment case in virtue of the
generality of the second term
and relatedly specific claims are likely
to lead to contradiction a common
strategy for creating a contradiction
pair is to just make sure you have two
sentences that exclude each other in
virtue of being very specific
so it's in virtue of patterns like this
that a system denied the premise can
nonetheless succeed in about 65 to 70
accuracy
let's get a little more precise about
what we mean by an artifact because i
think we need to think about this in a
nuanced way so my my definition
is that a data set artifact is a bias
that would make a system susceptible to
adversarial attack even if the bias is
linguistically motivated and let me give
you an example that brings out the
nuance there
consider negated hypotheses tending to
signal contradiction
this is a very natural thing
linguistically if you give me a sentence
like the dog barked and you asked me to
construct a contradictory sentence it's
very natural for me to say the dog
didn't bark by simply inserting a
negation
so it's not a surprise that this happens
it's linguistically motivated negation
is our best way of establishing the
relevant kind of connection
however here's the reason that this is
an artifact we could easily curate a
data set
in which negation correlated with the
other labels
but nonetheless this led to no human
confusion because humans are not really
operating at this general level of a
data set bias they're thinking about
individual examples and what they mean
but we know that our systems are going
to be very sensitive to the
distributions of things in their
training data and that's the sense in
which we can be adversarial in this way
and expose that a system has overfit to
a certain kind of regularity
here are some known artifacts this is by
no means exhaustive but i think this
will give you a sense for the kind of
things that you want to look out for in
nli context but also generally in
dealing with problems in nlu
so it's been observed that these data
sets contain words whose appearance
nearly perfectly correlates with
specific labels and what i mean here is
just randomly chosen words like cat and
dog
the reason for this is probably that
crowd workers were producing a lot of
examples and they fell into a pattern of
making specific lexical choices and that
created a spurious bias for one label or
another
entailment hypotheses over represent
general and approximating words we've
seen that that's systematic in terms of
the linguistic patterns but it's an
artifact because the world needn't be
this way for humans to succeed in making
their predictions
neutral hypotheses often introduce
modifiers this was a way that workers
found to create saints statements that
excluded each other with simple
modifications
contradiction hypotheses over represent
negation we've seen that and that makes
sense
and neutral hypotheses tend to be longer
and that last one is yet again another
case where
that's the sort of regularity that our
systems are going to be very good at
picking up on but that humans will
probably not make direct use of in
making predictions of their own and in
that way we can easily leverage this
observation to create an adversarial
setting for one of our models where
humans succeeded the task but our models
suffer because they're cued into the
wrong aspects of the underlying problem
to close this out i just want to
emphasize that artifacts are discussed a
lot in the context of nli i think that's
because a bunch of big benchmarks
appeared and people did a lot of probing
work to understand them but it does not
follow the nli as the only task where
the data sets have artifacts in fact i
would venture that every task that we
work on has associated data sets that
suffer from artifacts here i've given
you a sample from prominent nlu problems
where people have found artifacts that
are similar to the ones that i just
covered for nli and the overall lesson
is clear whatever problem you're working
on you should think critically about
your data and how idiosyncrasies in that
data might be affecting system
performance and creating a distance
between what you think you're doing in
terms of problem solving and what your
system is actually doing
and one way we can expose this is via
efforts involving adversarial testing
we're going to have a whole discussion
of this later in the quarter but i do
want to plant the idea here in
adversarial testing we're going to take
standard nli examples like this and
modify them in ways that expose that
systems have surprising gaps
so a prominent early example of this is
this wonderful paper by glockner at all
called breaking nli
what they did is very simple we're going
to operate with actual snli examples
here we would start with the premise a
little girl is kneeling in the dirt
crying
and a little girl is very sad which is
an actual snli example with the
entailment relation
we'll fix the premise what they did to
create their adversarial data set is
simply swap out sad for unhappy that is
to create pairs that are differ only
according to the synonyms that they use
this is only mildly adversarial but you
can see why this might be difficult
unhappy contains a negation and we might
have a hypothesis that systems will then
predict contradiction because they've
overfit to the association of negation
with contradiction and that's exactly
the kind of pattern that glockner had
all found and the overall takeaway here
is that these systems that we've
developed are not behaving
systematically in the sense of cognitive
science they're not behaving according
to the kinds of underlying intuitions
that human language users have their
patterns of errors are more surprising
and idiosyncratic leading us to worry
about their true capacity to generalize
let me show you one other example this
is from neon and it involves syntactic
variations so in this case we'll take
actual examples and fix the hypothesis
but now vary the premise so this is one
of their manipulations where they simply
swap the subject and object our original
premise is a woman is pulling a child on
a sled in the snow that entails a child
of sitting on a sled in the snow that's
good we would expect that if we modify
the premise so that the subject is a
child and the object is a woman this
would create the neutral label with
respect to our fixed hypothesis
but perhaps unsurprisingly need all
found that many systems were not
sensitive to this change in the premise
revealing that they were mainly making
use of the bag of words so to speak and
not truly attune to the syntactic
structure and that's so productive
because that specific lesson might lead
us to go looking for systems that are
more sensitive to syntax and therefore
would be not susceptible to this kind of
adversary and in that kind of productive
back and forth i think we can
triangulate on even better systems for
the next generation